foreign
is in Maui Hawaii hi Laura welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi guys I'm so grateful for you guys I
wish I discovered you sooner oh we're
glad you're here how can we help
um I just I don't know where to start
I'm I'm a stay-at-home mom my husband
and I have three little kids one on the
way one of them with special needs and I
made a lot of stupid choices in my 20s
and now we're about 200 000 in debt with
most of it coming from my student loans
um we have super high living expenses
that are like 60 of our income
um and I just feel like we can't ever
get ahead because we're always just
trying to make ends meet and I I know
that we live an expensive place housing
wise but I don't really want to move
because my daughter can get Services
here and you know I want my husband to
bring in more income either by going
back to school or getting a new degree
or taking on another high-paying job but
I also feel like I needed help at home
because our kids are still young and I
just feel so stuck and uh I want him to
pick up his income but I also just I
just don't know if that's the answer or
where to start well I'm sorry kid you
got a lot on you
a house full of little kids is enough
one of them special needs adds a double
dose doesn't it
yeah a lot going on how old are you
um 31 now okay and the kids are what
ages
three two nine months that alone just
spells cray-cray
so it's so intense you don't even need
debt to be overwhelmed you've got it
right there
I don't blame you a bit I don't blame
you this is just a hard time for y'all
okay that's a lot of work there's a lot
of emotion a lot of drama in the air and
then pile 200k a dead on top of it right
okay yeah so there's not a magic switch
we can throw that makes us go away
okay in terms of the debt
um as you have already figured out and
alluded to there's going to be some
trade-offs
something's going to give
if you want this debt to go away and
you're gonna you're gonna pay a price of
some kind
for this debt to go away I don't know
what that price is but you've already
figured out that that's your only way
right it's not because it's not going to
magically disappear
so
um and it's not bankruptable so it is an
income
versus outgo
formula you've already alluded to that
you know that
so it's income up
out go down
student loan goes away
now what's going to give
hey you guys get to make these choices
you're grown-ups but you can't sit there
and expect
uh Puff the Magic Dragon to show up he's
not coming
so hubby's not going to be around to
help you and you're going to be a little
bit even crazier in an already
overwhelmed situation with three littles
and one of them was special
and um it's gonna be hard and because
he's working all the time because we got
to clean the student loan debt up so we
can have a future
or
we move and we find some other way to
get services for the little
or
both
but you see what I'm saying something's
going to give something's going to leave
a mark something's going to be ouchy
right now the algae is the student loan
but if you want it to move away there's
going to be you're going to trade it for
another ouchy
does that make sense
yeah so embrace the suck
yeah you're right it's gonna suck you
just got to figure out which one and
what I like about this is you get to
choose your suck
I mean if we could if we had a time
machine we'd send you back and not do
this okay but you know hey you know if
none of us ever made mistakes I'd never
have a radio show so there you go right
so I mean this is how this works so
you're okay you're just a human being
screwed up welcome to the race you know
we all do this right I got a PhD in Dumb
kiddo I've done stupid stuff makes your
stuff look smart
so I mean I get it but it's I but you
can't it's not gonna we can't just go I
wish you know so so something's gonna
suck what is it and you and your husband
sit down and put the kiddos to bed get
them all asleep at one time which is a
minor miracle in itself and we're gonna
have it not We're not gonna watch Tiger
King on Netflix we're gonna talk about
this crap and we're gonna go okay what
is it in our life that for the next
three years is gonna suck and be really
hard so that this sucky student loan
goes away
mm-hmm
yeah
because you named everything you needed
to do you just didn't want to do it and
I'm I'm coaching you up here
yeah this let this beer Line in the Sand
moment I mean it's hard as a mom of
little babies too it is it is a hard
season but this is just gonna be a
season this isn't Gonna Last Forever
both with the kids being tiny and it
being hard and also with paying off this
debt yeah it's not 10 years from now it
will not be the same
yeah it won't be
I mean kids are easier to raise when
they're older
if you let them live that long they get
better
[Laughter]
I wish I thought about a family in my
20s or younger so that I wouldn't have
made all the stupid decisions I made
well me too
I wish I wished I hadn't borrowed three
million dollars when I was 26 and gone
broke when I was 28 when Sharon had a
brand new baby at home and would have
left but we didn't have a car she was so
pissed at me she couldn't see I wished I
hadn't done all that but I did do it and
then I had to embrace the suck to get
rid of it
but do you recommend we move States
do you think that would help us I'm not
sure
I recommend that the two of you look at
it and say what is it that's going to
suck and we're going to choose
okay we're going to choose your you're
going to go back to school and work take
this job you're going to work 60 hours a
week and I'm gonna be like a single mom
over here pulling my freaking hair out
we're going to move States we're going
to do all three of these things uh but
you know or we're going to choose to sit
in a student loan and look at it and it
sucks because we're going to just keep
doing what we're doing right now but at
least choose don't feel like it's
happening to you you choose and when you
do that you're going to make a good
choice
and you're going to make one you're
willing to embrace
Laura are you ready for that
um I'm scared but I feel like not being
able to make ends meet news a lot so
yeah I'm ready I think you're ready when
you get when people get sick and tired
of being sick and tired that's when
they're ready to do anything
and it's in your voice I can hear it
you're you're over it you're done you're
like Something's Gotta Give
and all the fear and shame let that go
let that drive you forward like don't
live in that fear and that all Coulda
Woulda Shoulda like that's done it's
time to move forward
because we've all done it kiddo the rear
view mirror is smaller than the
windshield for a reason it's called
Grace